[Musique]
cette vidéo est réalisée par des
agriculteurs alors qu'il s'apprête à
remorquer des camions russe
l'un des camions est équipé d'un système
de missiles sol-air panchir
cet ami de l'ex andres a aujourd'hui
trois véhicules russe dans son jardin ou
plutôt ce qu'il en reste
nous en avons réparé 2 et les avons
donné à l'armée ukrainienne
sur les autres on peut récupérer les
pièces détachées si l'un des véhicules
de nos soldats tombent en panne nous les
aiderons bien sûr
regardé celui ci était blindée c'est une
rareté il a un verre super épée mais ça
ne les a pas sauvés
rien ne laisse à aura sur notre
territoire mi mars les forces du
craignait non repousser les troupes
russes hors de la ferme où travaillent
andrier
les russes ne sont pas restés longtemps
dans nos champs donc ils n'ont pas eu le
temps de poser des mines mais j'ai
entendu dire qu'ils ont miné les terres
d'autres agriculteurs en amène droit
quant aux terres d'alexandre la plupart
est occupée par les forces russes
alors qu'il nous emmène voir les
quelques chants encore libres il appelle
sa soeur qui se trouve dans la zone
occupée
ils sont en train de tirer là
tout le temps il ya constamment des tirs
d'un côté et de l'autre et y at-il de
l'électricité dans le village non il n'y
en a plus depuis deux semaines
ils n'ont retrouvé leurs réseaux mobiles
que ce matin carrément
il y à des soldats russes dans le
village
et ils ont viré le garde de sécurité de
notre ferme
les habitants nous disent qu'ils ont
conduit des tanks à travers nos champs
et même creusé des tranchées
actuellement olexandre ne peut accéder
qu'à 600 de ses 5000 hectares et à un
seul de ses huit tracteurs
presque toutes nos machines agricoles se
trouve sur les terres occupées et il
s'agit d'équipements qui coûte cher de
plus nous venons juste de finir de
rembourser nos prêts et toutes nos
semences sont là bas ainsi que la
plupart des engrais et des pesticides
le blé semé en hiver n'aura que la
moitié des ongrais par rapport à
d'habitude et même si alexandre
parvenait à faire quelques récoltes
cette année il ne sait pas ce qu'il
pourrait en faire dans cette grange nous
avons plus de 500 tonnes de graines de
tournesol
normalement nous devrions les vendre au
producteur d'huile de tournesol mais en
ce moment nous ne pouvons pas les
acheminer vers les usines et de toute
façon tous les ports sont bloqués ils ne
peuvent donc pas exporter 2000
en temps normal l'ukraine fourni plus de
40% de l'huile de tournesol mondiale et
la plupart des exportations se fait par
voie maritime mais aujourd'hui deux
ports sont occupés deux autres subissent
des attaques et si odessa et demeurer en
grande partie indemne jusqu'à présent
les navires de guerre russes rendre ces
ports inutilisable une situation qui
pousse les agriculteurs à demander une
aide pour trouver des voies alternatives
si tu as moins
aujourd'hui notre capacité d'exportation
et des dizaines de milliers de fois
inférieures à ce qu'elles étaient
lorsque les ports étaient ouverts
et l'ukraine fourni de la nourriture au
monde entier il devrait donc y avoir une
réaction forte de la part des
organisations internationales mais il
n'y en a pas eu
le sol exceptionnellement fertile de
l'ukraine en fait un acteur clé sur les
marchés alimentaires mondiaux
voici notre terre noire elle nourrit les
gens en ukraine mais aussi à l'étranger
dans le monde entier
c'est notre terre et notre gagne-pain
ans mais même dans les zones éloignées
des combats la récolte de cette année
sera très réduite
nous ne pensions pas qu'il y aurait la
guerre dont certaines des graines que
nous n'avions pas encore acheter nous
pensions les acheter au printemps
on devait les commandes et à kharkiv
mais là bas les fournisseurs ont vu
leurs stocks détruit la ferme se portant
bien récemment lioudmila et son mari ont
acheté une nouvelle voiture aujourd'hui
l'agricultrice espère planter autant que
possible pour que les ukrainiens ne
souffre pas de la fin mais sans espoir
de faire des bénéfices lui même sort
cette guerre a bouleversé nos
malgré tout olexandre et ses amis
essaient de se détendre de temps en
temps en pique-niquant dans cette
réserve de chasse
ils sont également venues nourrir les
sangliers de la réserve mis en danger
par l'occupation russe
leur nourriture et coincer la barre il
ne nous reste que de quoi tenir une
semaine
si les sangliers devait être libéré cela
serait la fin de la réserve de chasse